puisque je suis sur un pied parlons
danse je m'en vais vous commentez le
merveilleux chef-d'oeuvre la mort du
cygne de camille cinq sens
extrait du carnaval des animaux au fur
et à mesure les évolutions
chorégraphique la grande danseuse étoile
mademoiselle clara bouchons mais je vous
resterai quelques extraits de la prose
de madame chagos antara dîner de meggie
intitulé le signe et dans le lac
monsieur herbert von siemens musique but
lorsque le jour à déchirer le rideau de
la nuit les roseaux frémissent à nice
comme des filles de joie frileuse et
jolie et derrière les roseaux qui qui
dort dans sony ainsi un cygne blanc
comme une hermine et qui s'étire comme
un des fers dans son lit alors dû bien
oui oh et les voilà qui se lance aussi
comme un patineur sur son lac gelé
formule m sont l'un au lac prolonge
encore sa carrière mais le vilain
chasseurs attirer aux caisses qui la
font toucher le signe va mourir non
blessé seulement laissé seulement et il
repart comme un grand enfant de plumes
frétillant des gauches
mais à droite même mais il a perdu des
forces au et là je le sens le signe va
mourir blessés seulement et il repart
canadie sempiternel
la mort le talonne mais il joue avec la
mort est le talonne au mans il ricane
entre ses ailes d'ange qu'on a cassé
mais il a mal
mamadou sylla my ans qu'est ce qu'il a
mal aussi
il a très mal aussi et ça commence à
bien faire pis bouchet bouchet filets
sont en haut que c'est aph
on le vit la bouger mais qu'est ce qu'il
va faire et là bas le signe est allé
mourir dans les roseaux le ciment voilà
écoutez finissant en chasseur on le
croyait le tableau et cette foi et cette
fois là bas au bord de la cascade le
cinéma dans le jour qui descend
ça y est le signe et mentalement c'est
pas un signe c'est un éléphant
mais comme le chef-d'oeuvre le signe il
est immortel